Fall and winter are basically non existent where I live
in Southwest Florida, so I am very,
very picky about the clothes I purchased for cold weather season
because I only get to pick,
like, one or two things because I just don't wear a whole lot.
And I saw this real life fleece shirt from Outdoor Nation,
and I knew I had to have it.
It is a microfiber fleece.
It's really warm. This is gonna be, like,
my only staple item that I wear all fall and winter long.
It has snaps, so, like,
if you live in the cold weather,
you can easily layer this,
but I can wear it as, like,
my outer layer jacket. Super comfy,
super cozy. For me,
this is a size small. It has nice coverage.
It has these pockets, and everything is snaps,
which I really, really like because sometimes zippers get stuck.
This is a really cute piece.
You can layer it or wear it as another jacket.
Super, super comfy.
And I cannot wait for our cool days that we do get to rock this.